Until now we've been using Docker
to run and install containers.
But I'm going to show you that you can
also use Docker as a build environment.
First let's build our application.
You may have already done
this in a previous lesson.
I'm going to make a new directory to
hold our source code then I'm going to
change into that directory and
clone the example application.
With the source code in place,
we're ready to build our
monolithic app from lesson 1.
After that's built, we're finally ready
to create a container for our app.
We'll start by looking at our Dockerfile
for the monolith on this line we're
copying over the monolith built artifact
from the go build command earlier.
The next line is where we
declare our entry point for
the container which will
be the monolith app.
So with the Dockerfile and
a monolith binary in place.
We are ready to build
the monolith Docker image.
We'll use the Docker build command
to upload our build context
to the remote Docker daemon which
will execute the Docker build command
listed in the Dockerfile.
This will reproduce an image for
the monolith application.
Now that the Docker build is complete
use the Docker images command to list
the monolith image.
Let's make sure the monolith image is
good by using the Docker run command to
create a container from it.
Now that we have a running
monolith container use the Docker
inspect command to grab its IP address.
And now are we're ready to
test the monolith container
using the cURL command.
It works!
As you can see, building container
images are breeze when using Dockerfiles
and the Docker build command.